hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well do we talk about
we don't say instead we debate right and
wrong right should do the right thing
why should you where do we learn about
where we learn about that sort of stuff
right well I mean as we learn the wrong
stuff we're learning it from our parents
if we don't have parents that it's you
know it's on those grandparents
whoever's raising us the first network
to manage somebody is actually nurturing
us raising us telling us things to do
who else who else is very important
really on yeah now this is not something
that the Mantis talks about in part
because of the Greeks worried we're
mostly schooling a man at home right
they didn't have public school systems
at
that time it was mostly at home and then
later on as your kids got older you'd
hire a tutor or you decided to go to a
school or something like that but this
would apply where else do people get
their ideas of writing long from fairly
really well apart because the TV kids
cartoons
you know actually kids cartoons there's
moral messages that's what every once in
a while
parents get upset about this cartoon and
that cartoon here's a great example you
know none of you have kids right now
right when you have kids would you let
your kid watch Family Guy when they're
five you would watching you know
American Dan Archer and a lot of these
you know adult cartoons they're not
adult because there's a lot of nudity or
anything like that they're adults
because there's people behaving very
badly and there's not that sort of you
know wrap it all up at the end good
triumphs over evil kind of thing too
isn't it
why don't you know I don't want my kids
to learn elsewhere too early as well
later so I hope that's not open to
something watch Family Guy there's a
whole bunch of things so we get this is
important are there any other sources
that we we get our ideas of right now
yeah I suppose we could do some other
things that would fall into like there's
certain certain atheist movements like
ethical culture you know whether the
very end to talking about regular on and
that they treat it very much like a
religious person was it sort of faith
Basavanna it would be a religion of the
state you know wow it's kind of funny
one of the things that the Chinese have
cracked down at in recent years model
who was you know great leaders but also
a horrible person
but a really strong guy a lot of taxi
drivers like images care about in their
taxis so like people of st. Christopher
metals over here they think it's going
to ward off accident because its power
it's a religious conviction and they
actually are trying to stamp it out this
is probably a pretty good list this is
probably fairly comprehensive you know
there's other sources by which we learn
about good and bad right now
Adam answer says let's look at what
people actually say do they say that
justice being a good person being a just
person following the rules not screwing
anybody over you know respecting other
people's rights giving people what they
deserve even when you don't have to do
they do they say that's a good thing for
you to have virtue is its own reward or
do they try to sweeten the deal when
you've asked your parents why do I have
to do the right thing what did they
answer you do they say because it is the
right thing you're obviously
misunderstanding the question you know
if you're a good day intelligence you
realize that right is its own concept
and you ought to be doing the right
thing because it's right thing probably
not right what do they say
yeah they they draw comparisons don't be
like those guys over there but why not
be doing yeah I mean those other kids
seem to be having a good time you know
sometimes they they say yeah doing the
right thing will make em feel good but
usually when you actually ask why do I
have to do the right thing it's because
you know doing the right thing that's
gonna make you feel good you got to give
something out that you want yeah yeah
look at my kid yeah so that's good well
how are you want others to treat that Oh
reciprocity yeah
and he doesn't talk so much about that
for that that's a good that's a good
consideration he talks about something
more like reputation or social become
the way you've looked at other people
being held in social esteem that's a
good kid good kid just they get a
reputation for being a good kid and then
what happens to good kiss
yeah they go yeah there's the used to
talk that much about the punishment
thing you get the idea that had a mantis
it's coming from the country and up
through a lot a lot of striking that may
not be the case for all of us I know I
had a good mix of the two
oh thing I grew up on the street where
there were very very few parents that
didn't do many sort of spanking or
things like that there were kids who are
spanked her kids were beaten and you
knew the difference back then there were
certain certain ways of sort of
disturbing and you know beating clear
cross routes which are lines
that good spanking who knows
get out that's the sort of here near
theater there there is a so there could
be a negative set here but what he lays
out is something possibly be a good
person because that's gonna lead to
reputation that's going to lead to
rewards what is it you're actually after
that
what are you family the rewards a maybe
the reputation reputation is one of
these goods that's both instrumental and
intrinsic this is the intrinsic good
this is what you really want justice is
just an instrumental good it's just good
for getting you the stuff that you want
now if you're telling kids stuff like
that what's the message the kids are
learning
yeah I'd agree that could reinforce the
natural egoism of them but it's also
telling them something about how they
ought to value it is how an intelligent
person the person who isn't you know
outside of the norms of their society
ought to put things in the balance so if
you get the rewards without being just
if justice is gonna cost you some stuff
get rid of justice right it's only good
because it leads to this stuff Adam and
this is pointing out something that does
happen in a lot of cases he says as well
if you think about the poets and when
he's talking about the poets he really
means what at that time was the media
and also to a certain extent the
religious leaders one of the poets say
they instead of saying social reputation
which they also talk about insofar as
they're talking about religion justice
will lead to the favor of the gods and
the gods that will give you blessings
and one of those blessings consistent
things you like things other people like
great and I've heard of CAP probably not
a blessing that you can relate to but
a sixth-century in a rural Greek person
that was the big thing what would be the
sort of blessings there are a lot of
people to talk to you know a lot of
these lines today you'd be good so that
God's gonna like you and God shower you
with blessings what are they kind of
blessings that we tend to like money
prosperity what else good mate you know
health lots of possessions opportunities
that what am I missing anything
listen protection security and horrible
deaths of your enemies now I don't I
usually go for that and some people like
to go for that as well but you see the
idea once again being you know in good
graces with the gods or God that's a
good thing it's really a good thing man
because it leads to blessings
and why should be just so God will like
you God doesn't like I'm just people God
will get that what happens in this case
again well justice is just an
instrumental bet so you're telling the
kids
hey you could do without the justice
part if the gods Hampton - like you
already don't worry about being just you
know don't try to cultivate a sense of
justice just you know take what you what
you're getting
the other thing that he has some of the
religious leaders actually saying if
they go to like the rich people they say
hey you know you've done a lot of bad
stuff but if you use your wealth and put
on games this is where again some of the
games in in Greece and Rome came from
games festivals that sort of stuff those
were religious festivals those were to
please the guys do this public service
none of God so you don't like you again
and when you die you're not going to go
to the bad place you're going to
a good place forget where your money
came from it's what you do now all that
matters is what you do with your
opportunities now forget that you
screwed over a whole bunch of people in
making that money you can take that
money and make it do something good and
then things will turn out well for you
now I got four kids here stuff like that
what's the message you're getting
so why is it make enough money exactly
that it doesn't really matter how unjust
you've been it's what's where you're
going don't don't me say stuff like that
separated then it's not who you were who
you are right now well you know a lot of
people think we've worked before
actually matters that you know somebody
wants me to invest the money with them
and they said yeah I screwed my
investors over before but that was the
old me would you trust them with your
money I sure wouldn't Bernie Madoff Kim
come on come came out of prison but
she's not going to do it this time I'm
gonna do it right and if you contribute
it's also going to go to charities and
how these work you should still
shouldn't invest so all these people are
giving messages that justice it's only
valuable because it gives you things
that you want it's instrumentally good
that's a big problem
now let me ask you this and this will be
the last thing that we'll talk about
with respect to this topic do you think
thinking about ancient Greek society a
little bit of it you gotta this is Plato
discussion in our society do you think
that kids are getting a better
understanding overall about justice not
what justice necessarily is but why just
why would be good to be just or do you
think we're getting a worse one for
giving our kids a worse idea or just say
it's about the same what do you think
I'm interested in here I know
you guys are different because they're
actually doing a lot newer but you're
closer to it did you get screwed up
ideas about the ethically through the
media that be smaller which I can no
more the heart of the world
well that's interesting okay
so they can see the consequences of
injustice that couldn't do that could
actually be a good thing we haven't
changed
yeah the need is there yeah it really
pervades our lives in ways I made you
know I'll get it this bit here cellphone
you've got like instantly access to all
these different ten minutes so there may
be the certain respects it's different
if you're gonna follow you're just
retching okay maybe it's written
respects it's tougher and other respects
it's easier I don't know the the media
itself is kind of a double-edged sword
because if you want to get some good
message out it's easy to do if you want
to get some bad message out it's also
easy to do easier than it wasn't ancient
Greek times right where you have to like
hire somebody to shout it or write it
down and hope some your home would catch
on